[Musique]
bonjour qui s'amusent joseph bonjour
movie violon beau jour aux auditeurs de
martinique 1ère vous est inconnu dans
vos activités professionnelles dans le
secteur du bâtiment et travaux publics
christian louis joseph que vous êtes
également docteur en économie
dimanche à christian louis joseph
dimanche ce sera le huitième
anniversaire du soulèvement du 5 février
2009 on le rappelle soulèvement social
sur des revendications contre la vie
chère contre l'opacité sur la
fabrication des prix et puis plus de
justice sociale
y at il des bruits de similitudes entre
aujourd'hui 2017
et il ya huit ans du point de vue
marqueur économiques influant joseph non
tout d'abord laissez-moi vous dire qu'un
diplôme d'économie n'est pas une
garantie pour ceux qui écoute écoute
l'économiste en question et beaucoup
d'économistes des sottises qu'y at il de
commun entre aujourd'hui et 2009
beaucoup de choses et en même temps pas
grand chose je n'ai le pont ce moment
mais je m'explique le mouvement de 2009
se situe dans une conjoncture très
particulier vous avez depuis 2000 2000
2001 développement économique accélérée
sous l'effet de la finale fut la
défiscalisation vous avez le bond du btp
mais en même temps en même temps la
partie la plus pauvre de la population
continue de s'appauvrir et les
inégalités augmentent en martinique
autour de 1 peu avant 2008 2006-2007 mai
2008 avec la crise financière
internationale vous avez une flambée des
prix
puis des matières premières prix du
carburant notamment et une partie des
couches moyennes sont également touchés
par ces augmentations de prix et sautent
l'eau pouvoir d'achat et constate que
l'on pouvoir d'achat diminue
considérablement
c'est là la clé ici et là et là ça fait
beau et dans ce mouvement
vous avez d'ailleurs à travers ce mot
vous avez il ya eu beaucoup de l'analyse
sociologique sur la culture etc
ce mouvement tout à fait exceptionnel
mais ce qui est ce que j'en ai retenu
c'est le mot profitation je crois qu'à
travers ce slogan
les manifestants ne dénonçaient pas
seulement la cherté de la vie mais
dénoncer l'injustice le fait que cette
fierté de la vie profité à certains et
pas la majorité de la population alors
2017 et choses ont-elles changé
2010 est la situation économique ne
s'est pas améliorée si vous regardez les
coupes du chômage alors je laisse de
côté le chômage au sens du bit est parce
qu ils sanctionnent en quelque sorte la
précarisation de la situation des
travailleurs lorsque vous avez travaillé
une heure dans la semaine
vous n'êtes pas chômé au sens du bit et
je préfère retenir le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi et je constate que
ce nombre de demandeurs d'emploi depuis
2006 n'a pas cessé d'augmenter
il y a une petite pause à fin 2015
une baisse mais qui est dédié tout
simplement aux emplois aidés
et puis probablement aussi à quelques
traitements statistiques qui permet de
faire des choses un chômage toujours
très très très fort des prix qui
continue de s'envoler les conditions
d'un nouveau 2009 sont selon-vous alors
je crois et je crée que la martinique se
soit installée dans une situation où
finalement vous ne risquez guère d'avoir
de réaction de ce genre ou alors si vous
avez une réaction
je crois qu'il sera ce sera une
explosion qui sera beaucoup plus
violente que celle de 2009 mais
malheureusement et qu'elle pourrait être
ce déclencheur pour matière de vin vide
en matière de mouvement social ça peut
être n'importe quoi et vitres teintées
oui oui rien ne serait plus j'ai presque
mineurs va dire aux auditeurs que vous
seriez tout comme moi je souris tout
comme vous oui non je ne crois pas je ne
pense pas que ce mouvement est nommément
de ses deux succès donc ça peut surgir
de n'importe quoi un incident banal un
affrontement entre des jeunes et les
forces de police sur une raison
quelconque
et ça peut repartir mais je crains
malheureusement que ce à quoi il faut
réfléchir ces homos de dystopie qu est
ce qu une dystopie c'est une cote
l'utopie c'est le contraire d'une utopie
c'est le fait d'imaginer un société qui
tourne au cauchemar et la population
antillaise à mon avis a réagi à la cites
est en train de réagir à la situation
que nous connaissons de la manière la
plus horrible qu'ils le soient c'est à
dire
lian en et migros et cette dystopie à
laquelle je pense c'est une en tunique
peuplé de retraités et le chômeur est où
la force des politiques en ont
conscience et sociologue dans nos
consciences vous vous vous l'évoquez ce
matin les martiniquais envoient leurs
enfants faire des études ailleurs et ses
enfants ne veulent pas revenir sauf pour
les vacances chez papa et maman
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire contre ça
puisque tout le monde a en mai les
raisons de cette fuite
oui mais tout le monde en parle et je ne
sais pas sion fait grand chose sur les
séminaires des conférences de presse des
colloques
prenez prenez l'exemple de cette
régulation des prix des conséquences de
la loi contre l'avis le chien de 2012
lorsque vous allez sur le site de
l'observatoire des prix de la tunique
il n'y a pas grand chose qui fonctionne
toujours alors justement on peut se
poser la question de savoir s'il
fonctionne toujours
vous allez sur le site de la réunion
vous y trouvez des études
vous y trouvez des recherches sur celui
de la matinée qu'il y a rigoureusement
ils figurent trois petites choses
nutrition reprise de lille c'est je
crois qu'ils que que personne ne s'est
véritablement attelé à la racine du
problème et peut-être que je devrais le
faire essentiellement les politiques
je crois que dawson où sont tous au plus
responsable je peux social université
les événements de 2009 faut quelqu'un
qui aurait suivi l'évolution des choses
ces événements étaient parfaitement
prévisibles
parce qu'on pouvait mesurer la perte de
pouvoir d'achat des plus défavorisés
cela n'a pas été fait at on mis en place
les moyens de suivre de près la
conjoncture
au delà des éléments très globaux que
fournissent bien des remous l'insee il
fallait il faut entrer au fond des
choses et suivre de près les réalités
économiques de ce pays
ce n'est malheureusement pas fait alors
je signale que la précédente région
avait créé un institut of avait
contribué à la création d'un institut
nantis les quais de statistiques et
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
je crée que pour des raisons politiques
on jette le bébé avec l'eau du bain
c'est à dire que cette situation crée
transparaît dans l'autre sens et je
laisse à ce sujet un appel
il faudrait peut-être que la ctm se
donne les moyens d'euros point de cet
outil est d'en faire ce qu'elle est
inutile
christian louis joseph on vous a déjà
entendu sur cette antenne dire que 2009
avait surtout servi la cause de la
classe moyenne
e en effet en effet il y a il y avait un
accord de salaire et cétacés et
plusieurs accords mais quand on
considère l'accord sur les salaires
d'une part il offrait 200 euros par mois
aux salariés qui touchait moins de semis
4 à moins de 400 euros disons simplement
et 4% d'augmentation à ceux qui
touchaient plus le problème c'est que
ceux qui ont eu les 4 % d'augmentation
ont conservé ses quatre pour cent qui se
sont impliqués directement à la salle
est alors que ce qui touchait les 200
euros ne les touchait qu'à la condition
que l'état et le conseil régional et le
conseil général d'ailleurs contribuer au
versement des cds 100 euros l'état et
les collectivités ont repris leurs
billes quelques temps prenant 12 ans et
même pas et finalement les salariés qui
devait toucher ces 200 euros se sont
retrouvés seulement pour certains avec
seulement 3 euros c'est-à-dire beaucoup
rire quand pour ça et certes est avec
rien du tout la cgt estimait à l'époque
deux ou trois un prêt qu'à peine le
tiers des salariés du privé avaient
bénéficié de cet accord c'était il n'y a
pas eu de alors ce qu'il faut souligner
aussi c'était très glh tout cela c'est
ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'il n'y a eu
aucune suite c'est à dire qu' il était
prévu de suivre la corde revenir si ses
conditions d'application
rien de tout cela n'a été fait et cela
me laisse très perplexe ou alors qu'à
maximiser rien du tout de notre société
à prendre à bras le corps les vrais
problèmes la martinique et du rien du
tout je ne dirais pas ça c'est un pays
qui est plein de potentialités qui sait
la petite tape dans le dos l'un e
non c'est non non non je le crois parce
que vous savez contrairement à ce que
croient les gens il y a énormément de
personnes qui sont qui travaillent les à
des chefs d'entreprises qui sont
performants il ya les i
et qui sont novatrices simplement il
faudrait peut-être que tout le monde
cherche allé dans le même sens que
celles où joseph e
fo ne faut tirer ne faudrait-il pas
expliqué en martinique est tout
simplement que vu le contexte insulaire
à bien la vie sera toujours plus cher
qu'ailleurs chez nous je ne sais pas si
on peut dire ça comme ça disons qu'il y
a
les jeux se passe souvent en dynamique
ce qu'il ce qui les touche n'est pas
souvent les nouveaux les niveaux absolus
ce sont les évolutions maintenant côté
côté niveau absolu côté évolution il
faut bien voir que vous avez nez car le
prix je prends les publics comme exemple
le travail que fait france antilles en
publiant un écart sur un certain nombre
de produits entre la martinique et la
métropole cet écart est de l'ordre de 30
32 34 % il aurait semble-t-il encore
augmenter mais il ne s'agit que de
quelques produits et les pôles et la
consommation des martiniquais n'est pas
faite que de produits importés les
ordinateurs il marque faune sont
exactement il y à il y a un travail à
faire permettant de savoir quelle est la
part des produits importés dans la
formation des martiniquais et d'en
déduire
finalement la cherté relative de la vie
cela dit est ce qu effectivement le bon
objectif est d'avoir des prix qui soient
les mêmes qu'en métropole ça c'est une
question qui relève un peu de la
philosophie politique
personnellement je ne crois pas mais ce
qui faut il chercher c'est éviter la
détérioration et chercher l'amélioration
surtout pour les plus démunis est ce que
les acteurs sociaux le corps patronales
les organisations syndicales l'état
est-ce qu'ils ont conscience de tout ce
que vous le dire est ce qu'ils se
rencontrent encore le dialogue social
tellement parlé le dialogue social en
panne j'appartiens une branche
professionnelle qui connut un dialogue
social efficace depuis depuis plus de 30
ans
même beaucoup plus haï dernière déjà du
doigt sur la table à chaque écoute et
dialogue dialoguer ne veut pas dire
c'est des atouts à n'importe quel moment
et à n'importe quel prix nous avons su
accepter des revalorisations dans quand
la conjoncture le père me tais quand la
conjoncture ne permet pas que les
entreprises n'ont pas de travail on
essaie lui et ses chants ses champs dans
le dialogue social doit quel que soit le
secteur est ce que ce sont des est-ce
que ça peut être lieu où des indications
sont données qu'on voit monter cette
colère ou dix ans de l'agrandissement de
la population qui peut exploser à
n'importe quel moment
lorsqu il y à un dialogue continu avec
des organisations syndicales entre
organisations syndicales organisations
patronales
on sent monter des choses nous nous le
sentions en 2009 que là que là que la
crise en 2008 2009 que la crise allait
exploser
parce que nous rencontrions de manière
régulière cela dit il ne faisait 1017 il
ne faut pas oublier il ne faut pas
oublier qu'en fait la crise si elle
droit de des lieux explosion concerne
surtout ceux qui ne sont pas et serré
dans le monde du travail et qui sont le
plus en plus nombreux vous avez quand
même plus de 50000 de moder d'emploi
nantis les riches énorme merci d'avoir
avec notre histoire de joseph on
rappelle que vous êtes docteur en
économie est connu également pour vos
activités professionnelles dans le btp
merci bonne journée
merci à vous bonne journée
m